The answer is we want to do the third thing.
We want to show some way that if we had the totient of n
we could also factor n.
That would show that finding the totient is not easier than finding the factors.
Of the other choices, the first one is actually not true.
If we have p and q, it's actually easy to compute the totient of n,
and it's easy because we know the totient of n is (p - 1)(q - 1).
The second answer is not true, but if it were, it wouldn't help us prove that RSA is hard.
It would just show that there might be an easier way to compute the totient of n
than there is to factor.
This would be damaging for our security proof.
Fortunately, at least for the security of RSA, the third one is true,
and next we'll show why.